May I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness in the heart of
the most holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my existence
by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother, Mary,
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants, or desires, and may you,
my beloved divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to
your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your
good pleasure, and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will, that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the
angels and saints, especially my sweet mother, Mary, to touch my forehead to imprint on it the
holy spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are
in these writings and prayers. Amen. This evening, we have a wonderful message from the Lord. I'm
beginning to point out to you that the messages that come to us usually come in groups and all
the messages tonight are saying something very interesting to us, that the divine will is the
servant of man. And if the divine will is the servant of man, then it behoves man to become the
servant of the divine will. So that's where we're at. We begin at January the 10th, 1926.
Louisa said, I was fusing myself in the holy divine volition and the littleness of my mind
wandered in it. I could see the divine will everywhere and in every place always in the act of operating
in the whole of creation. Oh, how I would have wanted to follow the divine will in order to give
it my little requital of love in everything it was doing. That's quite a tall order considering that
we're such small finite beings. I wanted to give it my thank you, my profound adoration and my meager
company. Now, while I was thinking of this, my adorable Jesus moved in my interior. So again,
I just want to remind you since we're beginning a series of classes that moving in her interior
means the kingdom of God is there. So that's Luke 17 21. And it's 1 Corinthians 3 16. No, you not
that you are the temple of the living God. Luke 17 says the kingdom of God is within you. Jesus
said, my daughter, my will is always on the way in the creation things. That means it's always
approaching you. It's always coming to you. I won't use that expression on the way all the time because
I'll use something that is more familiar to us. The divine will is always approaching us. Or as
the scriptures tell us, God is always passing by. And as God passes by, the invitation is for us
to be able to receive him and to let him do what he wants. So he said, my will is always on the way
and created things in order to go towards the creatures. In other words, God is active in
absolutely everything in order to be able to serve us. But who fulfills it? Who places the final
point on the work of my will? It's the creature. It's also. Or rather, the creature who takes all
created things as the fulfillment of my will. Now, all human beings benefit. But the ones that
the Lord wants to stress are the ones who are doing everything in his divine will. So we give a much
more complete response to him. So he now gives us an explanation. And he gives us the long story of
a seed going into the ground. And all that has happened to it become a plant. And all that has
happened that plant in order to become bread on our table. And this is the divine will on its journey
towards us, serving us at every single point. And he wants us to be aware of the fact that when
we eat the piece of bread, that we realize just how many miracles he has worked to achieve that.
And he has a point in saying this, which we will get to. My will makes its way in the seed.
That means it's already working towards you. It has you in mind in the seed. And it makes the
earth receive it while giving it the power of making it germinate and multiply. The divine will
performs its crafting by calling the water to water at the sun to fecundate it the wind to
purify it the cold to make it take root the heat to develop it and to make it reach proper
maturity. So there you've got the divine will in all the elements working on that seed. The divine
will gives power to the machines to cut us. Now notice human beings would claim all that power
for themselves. We made the machines you see. The divine will give power to the machines to
cut it to treasure to grind it so as to be able to give it the substance of bread.
And calling the fire to cook it, it offers it to the mouth of the person
so that she may eat of it to preserve her life. See then what a long journey
and what the amount of work that the divine will has done in that seed to nourish you.
How many things it has called over that seed in order to make it reach as bread they mouth of
his children. Now who gives the final step to the way of my will or the journey of my will
and the fulfillment of the final act of my supreme volition. It's one who takes that bread
and eats it as the bearer of the divine will. That's the important thing.
The one who is the bearer of the divine will so that we're actually eating in the divine will.
And as the person eats that bread, she eats my will in it to increase the strength of her body
and soul. So you'll notice that people who have no faith whatsoever can be eating at a very low
level of just simply the animal feeding itself. But he's expecting us to perform this action of
feeding ourselves from the highest possible level of fulfilling the divine will.
So as she eats, she eats my will to increase the strength of her body and soul as the divine will's
fulfillment in everything. The creature one can say is the center of the rest to which my will
aspires in all things. In other words, she's the destiny. He's done everything for us. Everything
was created for us. And the crafting that the divine will makes in all things in order to reach
the creature. In other words, the divine will has made itself our servant to provide this food for us.
And it's his joy if we would participate with him in the divine will so that the nourishing of
our bodies is also at the same time the nourishing of our souls. He says it's the same with all the
other things which serve man. My will makes has its journey in the sea and it works in the multiplication
of the fish. It has its journey on the earth and it multiplies plants, animals and birds.
It has its journey in the celestial fears in order to have everything under its eyes so that
nothing may escape it. And the divine will may make itself feet, hands and heart for each creature.
I think we need to take that a little bit on board. He makes himself feet, hands and heart for us.
We would say that of a mother for her babies. But it's not our concept of the infinite everlasting
omnipotent creator of the universe. The divine will makes itself feet, hands and heart for each
creature to offer to each one of them the fruit of its innumerable harvest. But all its feast
is only for those who take of its own that is of the divine will as the final point and fulfillment
of its supreme volition. So the divine will feeds everything all creatures, plants, animals, humans
but where he actually feasts, where he rejoices and celebrates is that when one of us, his children
receives it in the divine will and lets it nourish body and soul as well. If it wasn't for my will,
which with its fiat was released, left itself available in all created things in order to make
them reach man so that the supreme fiat might find its first place in man, in the one for whom
all things has been created. You can see that the destiny is man all the time. He's doing all of
this for us. And so we were told in Genesis chapter two that all things were made for Adam
and that everything was put together as a wonderful paradise before Adam was created and put into
this paradise where everything was available for him. God did it. It was entirely his thing and
that's what Jesus is reminding us of here that God has put everything in the universe for us.
We're completely spoiled children to the point of not remembering what the father has done for us.
So if it wasn't for my will, which with its fiat was released, left itself available in all things
in order to make them reach man so that the supreme fiat might have its first place in the one for
whom all things were created. Therefore, being the ruler and the actor of the very life of the
creature, the supreme will should be. All things would remain paralyzed and like many painted pictures
in which the life of the things that they portray would be absent. If the divine will is not in them,
operating, then there's no reality there. So the poor creature, if my will withdrew from making
itself available in all created things, everything would just be painted pictures. That means no
reality. There would be no food there for us. There would be nothing for us and they would no
longer be producing the good that each thing contains for man. Therefore, I can say that it is not
created things that serve human beings. It is my will. So here's the statement that the divine will
is the servant. And if you have your own book, I think that this long sentence should really be
colored because this is the essence of the message. Therefore, I can say that it's not created things
that serve human beings, but it is my will veiled and hidden that makes itself the servant of man.
But just move from there to the extraordinary mystery of the Eucharist where Jesus remains
veiled and hidden but truly present as our ultimate food. Is it not right then,
the Lord says, that the most sacred duty is for man to look at my supreme will in all things
and to fulfill it in everything and returning the service to serve the one who does not
disdain to serve him even in the smallest things. Now he has really got around us. He's taken away
all our excuses. He says that if the infinite Almighty ever living everlasting omnipotent
creator of the universe goes to such trouble to serve you, the least you could do is respond.
It's fascinating. And I just want to remind you here that in Mark chapter 10 verse 45 Jesus says that
when he came in the incarnation he did not come to be served but to serve and to give his life as
a ransom for many. And therefore it's not just the divine will in its essence in the blessed trinity
that serves us. But when the word of God became flesh and dwelt among us that he also came to
serve as well. And that tells us that the extremely important thing for us is to serve,
is to give life to others. And so he says, I feel as though compensated and repaid for my
crafting when I see that these things reach the human being and that he takes them as the fulfillment
of my will. And therefore I make feast because the purpose of the long journey in the created
things has obtained its intent. In other words, what I set out to do I achieve. And the fulfillment
of my will is realized in the creature. Now he's going to illustrate this for us by talking about
an actor preparing a performance and all the work that's hidden in the background. And when it's
all ready and all the rest of it, then you pull back the curtains and way you have got this wonderful
play. But the enormity of the work that's gone on in the background, because that's what he's been
telling us here, the enormity of the work that goes on in creation to provide food for the children
of God. So Jesus says, it's the same as with an actor who must present a show to an audience.
The poor one, he has met many hidden works, how many vigils, how many preparations,
how much art does he not prepare even in his movements so that his postures may make the audience
smile or cry whatever part of the entertainment it is. In all this crafting, the actor doesn't make
feast. On the contrary, he sweats, he toils, he labors. And when everything seems to be prepared,
he prepares himself to call the public to see his show. And the more people he sees, the more he
feels joy in his heart for who knows, he might be able to make a beautiful feast. But the true
fulfillment of his feast is when the show, having been performed full-handed, he receives coins of
gold and silver flowing to his hands. In other words, the end product of the whole thing is that
he gets a response from the audience. There's nothing worse than an actor putting on a show
and the audience just sits there and does absolutely nothing. They're completely indifferent. That
would kill the thing dead. So they do this as appreciation and triumph of his show. But if after
so many preparations, he sets up everything he plays and he plays toys, trumpets and nobody shows
up or just a few people who leave him alone in the first acts of the show, poor one, how he suffers
and the hope of his feast turns into mourning. In other words, no response. Who is it that so much
embittered that poor actor is so capable and kind in performing the scenes? It is the ungrateful
people. See, here's the Lord taking all excuses away from us. That's totally gratitude on our part,
not to respond to the Lord in the way he asks. So now he lifts that illustration of the actor
up onto his level. Such is my will, he said. It's like a capable actor. It prepares the most
beautiful scenes in order to amuse man in the theater of the whole of creation and not to receive
but to give. Now Jesus has emphasized this all the time in these volumes that God is giving,
giving, giving. God is love and love lives by giving. And what kind of giving? If love doesn't
give all, it doesn't feel it has given at all. And so it's this lavish pouring out of everything
upon us that comes from God. And looking at Jesus' life and his passion and death, it's just,
it's almost unbelievable what he's done. The scene has been no limit to what he was prepared to do.
And all he wanted was to benefit us. There was nothing in it for himself.
And so the Lord expects us to give some kind of a response. And the more we respond with generosity
and love, the more he feasts. And so the divine will prepares feasts of light of the most
effulgent, scenes of flowerings and beauties, the most radiant, as scenes of strength in the
roaring of the thunder and the bursting of the thunderbolt in the continuous rising of the waves
and even in the height of the highest mountains. The most moving scenes of a baby who cries and
shivers and is numb with cold, sorrowful and tragic scenes of blood and even of death in my
passion. No actor as capable as he might be can match me in the variety of loving scenes provided.
But alas, how many people do not look at my will in all these scenes. And they do not take the substance
of the fruit which is in them. And they turn the feasts that my will has prepared in creation
and in redemption into mourning. Therefore, my daughter, let nothing escape you. This is the plea
to us. Take all things as a gift or lovely thing for our first class in the new year. Take all
things as a gift and a gift that my will specifically gives to you. Whether they are small or great,
natural or supernatural, bitter or sweet, take them all as gifts and the fulfillment of my will.
That would change everything, wouldn't it? I wonder how many people consider these
awesome lockdowns as a gift of contemplation. Time to get close to the Lord.
Time to really grow and holiness. Time to make reparation. So let's go to January the 24th,
1926. And we continue this message. Louisa said, "I felt all abandoned by heaven and by earth and
I thought unto myself that Jesus had told me a long time before that I was to live in the hard
exile of life as if there was nobody else but Jesus and myself." Now that's volume one and two.
Particularly volume one. That was when he was starting her off and he detached her from
absolutely everything outside in the world and even from her close contacts until he said,
"I now have got you. I've got your entire attention. Now we'll take it from here."
And so she continues remembering, "Everyone must disappear from my mind and from my heart."
Now I do remind you of the gospel where three men came to Jesus saying, "You know, I want to follow
you and all the rest of it." Jesus made it very clear to them that if you really genuinely want
to follow God, you need to break ties with the world and even with your family. Now by breaking
ties, I don't mean that you no longer love them and you no longer care for them but that there isn't
attachments that can actually pull you down and that nobody can manipulate you, that interiorly
you really are genuinely free to serve God. You really are available to him. You are not being
pulled and dragged in all directions by human beings. And so Louisa says, "Now after everything
has disappeared from me and I'm used to living only with Jesus, he has run away himself,
leaving me alone, pray to unspeakable bitterness in this hard state of isolation."
Now what Jesus does is he lets Louisa express something and she has expressed isolation.
That's what we're having in these lockdowns. That's why I think this message is fantastic
for our first one of 2021. He allows her to express the word isolation and then he picks it up
and shows her what she can do. Which is what we need, isn't it? So he's left me in this state of
isolation or God who are pain, have pity on me, come back to the one who feels the need of your life
more than her own life. Now this is a sure sign that somebody really has reached union with God,
that they won't God more than anything else. Do a little check on yourself for that one.
So now Jesus is going to pick up the word isolation and talk about it.
While I was thinking of this and of other yet more harrowing things, which would be too long
to say, "My sweet Jesus moved in my interior and sighing told me, 'Doctor of my supreme will
courage in your isolation.'" This serves as company for my will abandoned by creatures. So Jesus is
going to say to her, "Turn your isolation into reparation." Because the divine will has been
abandoned by creatures. As you know, like this brilliant, absolutely brilliant. We don't have
to be clever to make reparation to the Lord. Just use what's all around you. It's actually very simple.
The sorrow of the isolation of the divine will, or how much harder it is than yours.
My will is the mother of all the wills of creatures. Now this is new for us. We've been
dealing with this for a long time. So the divine will has given a will to us, has given us free will.
It's the mother, the one who gave life. As a most tender mother, she left herself in the center of
creation in order to deliver the human wills and to keep them all around herself, to raise them
upon her knees. Of course, if everything had remained that close to the Lord, the human race
wouldn't be in the terrible state it's in now, and to nourish them with the milk of her celestial
teachings, and to make them grow in her likeness, giving them all of creation in order to amuse
themselves. Here we're back at Genesis chapter two that all of creation was put together and
paradise was put together, and then the man was put into it. But that the Lord wanted the man
to be in union with him. It was the only way he could flourish. But since my will is the center of
each created thing, wherever the creatures would go, she is the center of all things and she would
remain always near them, more than an affectionate mother, that they might never lack her maternal
cares, nor descend from her nobility and likeness. So if man had never fallen, we would have an
extraordinary closeness to all the things that God has actually made. We would also know from
infused knowledge from him what to do with plants when we would become ill, because the answers are
in the plants, the answers to illness. So the Lord has spoken about the divine will in terms of mother,
but he also uses the term father as well. He's using our language, but here he's talking about
the divine will is mother. But alas, these daughters, the human wills, delivered by this celestial
mother, which is my will, despising and neglecting all of her maternal cares, her love, her tenderness,
her attention, and even though my will is near them, these human wills are far away from the mother.
Now all of us have had the experience of trying to communicate with the person and you're not being
received because they're not available to you at that moment. Their ears are closed, so it doesn't
matter what you say. It's not going to be received. And this is what Jesus is lamenting, that while
our wills are his gift, that our decision has taken them away from him. So poor mother,
these wills despise her and they make fun of her. They don't even know her, he said. Poor mother,
which is my will, in the midst of so many daughters delivered by her, she remains isolated and abandoned
just as Jesus remains isolated and abandoned in our churches. And you need to look into what's going
on that the world wants to isolate us from the Lord. There is something going on that is not good.
My will remains isolated and abandoned and while all of them take of what is hers in order to live,
they use it and they also grow in dissimilarity from her and defender. In other words, we have
to use the plants, we have to use the animals, we have to live, we have to grow and all the rest
of it. So we're using everything that the divine will has actually provided. And to do that and
also sin against the divine will is what he's pointing out here is the horror of how he sees things
on his side. Can there be a greater sorrow for a mother than the abandonment of her children?
Not to be known by the fruit of her own womb, which turning into enemies,
offend the one who brought them to the light. Therefore, the sorrow of isolation of my will
is great and inconceivable. This is Jesus' answer to Louisa's isolation and is telling her that she
is being asked to experience in her own way, in her own circumstances, something of the isolation
that he experiences in everybody's will is against him or who ignores him and therefore she can make
reparation on behalf of all. So may your isolation be the company of this mother who cries and searches
for her children, but as much as she cries, shouts and calls her children, whether with the most tender
voices or the most bitter tears, with the most ardent sighs or with the most thundering voices
or chastisement, these unruly children keep far away from the womb of the one who generated them.
My daughter, do you not want to share as the true faithful daughter of my will in her sorrow
and her isolation? So Louisa is being told the isolation that you're experiencing is not haphazard,
it has a deep meaning and so I'm now bringing you around to get you to understand this.
Now in the next long paragraph we have talked about chastisements and all the rest of it.
In other words, Jesus is going to explain these unruly children and why even the shouting of
chastisements is not affecting them. Now I've said to you a number of times but you know it's good to
say it at the beginning of the year as well and that is that if you look up Wikipedia and look up
history and look up a particular year, you will find out what has happened in that particular year.
So I want to give you an idea, this is 1926 and Jesus is going to talk about all kinds of
chastisements. I want to give you an idea of what was going on in the world in 1926. So when we read
about the chastisements, it's not just sort of words that is not touching some reality, it's
actually expressing what was going on in the earth. First of all, there was terrible flooding in
Cologne in which 50,000 people had to be evacuated. There was flooding in London, there was an
assassination attempt on Mussolini. There was a general strike of the coal miners in Britain,
a France bombed Damascus because of the Druze riots. There was a coup in Poland, a war in
Morocco was trying to come to an end. There was a military coup in Portugal, a bolt of lightning
blew up the military arsenal in New Jersey. So that was a strike from heaven. Lebanon became a
republic. There was a second assassination attempt on Mussolini. There was a terrible hurricane in
Miami in which a hundred people died. A hurricane killed 600 people in Cuba. The first mosque
was built in London. There was a village almost completely destroyed in the French Riviera from
a massive storm. There was a coup in Lithuania. There was civil war in Nicaragua, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera. Just to let you know that when he talks about chastisements, things were going on.
After this, Louisa said, "I began to do the adoration to my crucified good." But before my mind,
there passed a scene of a long line of soldiers, all armed off which never ended. Now this is
a preview of World War II she's getting. I wouldn't want to think about my crucified Jesus
rather than see these soldiers, but against my will I was forced to see these soldiers equipped
for anything. So I prayed my sweet Jesus to take the sight away from me that I might be free
to be with him. And Jesus all afflicted told me, "My daughter, the more it seems that the world is
apparently at peace." And they sing the praises of peace. The more they hide wars, revolutions,
and tragic scenes for poor humanity under that ephemeral and masked and therefore not true peace.
So I want to give you Psalm 62 verse 4 and Jeremiah 6, 14. They all cry peace, but they're planning war.
And Jesus continues, "The more it seems that they favor my church and sing hymns of victories and
triumphs and practices of union between church and state, the more the brawl is which they are
preparing against her." In other words, there is a pretense of accepting the church on the outside,
but they are completely against the church on the inside. Now this is 1926 and already the communists
and the Freemasons are infiltrating the church. The desperate situation we have now started there.
It was the same for me 2,000 years ago. Up until they had claimed me as king and received me in
triumph, I was able to live in the midst of the people. But after my triumphant entry into Jerusalem,
they wouldn't have let me live. And even only a few days later they should have crucified him.
At all taking arms against me, they made me die. When things do not start from the foundation of
truth, and this is the bit he wants us to really underline, and if you're using your own copy,
color it. When things do not start from the foundation of truth, they've no strength to reign for a
long time. Because since truth is missing, love is missing, and the life that is needed is also
missing. Therefore, what they were hiding easily comes out and they turn peace into war and favor
into revenge. Or how many unexpected things they are preparing. Now as we go on, the Lord will
reveal more and more to Louisa. So for that I want to give you Amos 3, 7. The Lord never does
anything without telling the prophets first. Jesus disappeared and Louisa said she remained
all afflicted, thinking to herself, "My beloved Jesus has told me many times that I'm the little
newborn of the divine will, just newly born without having formed my life in the supreme
volition. And now that I am the most in need in order to form my growth, Jesus leaves me alone."
So I will be like an aborted birth in the divine will without having existence. Don't you see
then my love? She says, "In what pitiful state I find myself and how your very designs upon me
are reducing me to nothing. Oh please, if you do not want to have pity on me, have pity on yourself
and on your designs and on your works which you have made for my poor soul." So Louisa is saying
to the Lord, "Don't you realize how greatly in need I am? And if you don't have pity on me,
why don't you have pity on the plans that you yourself said you wanted to accomplish through me,
therefore it had to accomplish in me? So why don't you do that?" But while her mind wanted to go
further into this sorrowful state that she was in, Jesus came out from within her interior and looked
at her thoroughly from head to foot, really examined her. It's very interesting. My daughter,
he said, "It is in my will there are neither debts nor abortions. This is extremely important."
Now what he does again is he allows her to sink something through and if she expresses something
that isn't complete or that needs explanation, he comes to her. So in the divine will, and she's
already in the divine will, she's inseparable from him, there are neither debts nor abortions.
And one who lives in the divine will contains as life, now this is the essence of our being,
the eternal life of the divine will. So if we have the eternal life of the divine will in us,
how can you have a death or abortion? You can't. And even if she feels herself physically dying
or even dead physically, she's in my will, which containing life that is eternal life.
And remember John chapter 6, "Anyone who eats this bread and drinks at my blood will have life."
He's talking about eternal life, indestructible life. Death cannot touch it.
So she's in my will, which containing eternal life makes her rise again in every instant
to new light, new beauty, new grace, new happiness, delighting in preserving her,
always little within itself, so as to have her great within itself. So he's underlying again
the fact that we have to come into this nothing place, so that we can move into the all.
The I am not must flow in the I am to have the complete circle, to have the complete reality.
And so he's saying to her that whatever diminishment that you think is happening to you and all the
rest of it, it's only to make you great in the divine will. But of course, during your lifetime,
he doesn't allow you to feel that too much in case you sit back and stop growing. And you say,
"Okay, I'm there." And at that point, you stop growing. He doesn't do that.
So you may be little, but you are strong. You may be little, but you are beautiful in God's eyes.
You may be just newly born so that you might have nothing human, but everything is divine
if you're completely living in the divine will. So your life is my will alone and it will carry out
all God's designs without dispersing anything. Now I've changed this slightly so that you hear
it that is happening in you, not just in Louisa. You will be like a drop of water submerged within
the great sea of the divine will. Like a grain of wheat amidst the great masses of grains,
as much as the drop of water seems as though it disappeared into the sea, just as the grain
amidst the innumerable grains, no one can deny or take away from them the right that their life
exists. The fact that you're only a drop of water in the sea of the divine will doesn't mean that
you're not in the divine will. You're absolutely immersed in it. The fact that you're one of these
grains, the fact that somebody else can't see this grain or its value or anything else doesn't take
from it at all, this wonderful thing. Therefore don't fear, he said, and make it so that you lose
your life in order to acquire the right to have my will alone as life. That's what Jesus said in
John 1224, "Lose your human life in order to gain the eternal life." In fact, he says in other
parts of the gospel as well that if you cling to the lore, you can't have the higher. You let go
of the lore and you receive the higher. Okay, so let's come into January the 28th, 1926.
So Jesus is going to talk about Adam before the fall, Adam after the fall. I heard a wonderful
long, that word which I'll give to you. I don't like long words myself. Pre-lapsarian Adam,
that's before the fall, and then Adam after the fall. Okay, so that would be post-lapsarian Adam.
So he's going to bring us right back to the beginning to show us that Jesus has to become
the tree of life for us, and it's only from him we can get the fruit of the divine will.
Now he comes back to Adam over and over and over and over again. It must be extremely
important for us to pick it up. So Louisa said, "I was thinking about the holy divine volition,
and I thought to myself, 'How can it be that Adam, after sin, having broken his will from that
of God?' He lost strength, he lost dominion, because that dominion was given to him in Genesis
chapter 2, dominion over everything. And his acts were not so pleasing to God as to form his delight.
Indeed, before sinning, Adam had done his acts towards God. He had learned them. Why then,
in repeating them afterwards, they no longer sounded the same note, and they no longer contained the
same fullness of divine love and complete glory to God. Now I would not think that was Louisa's
query. I think that the Lord has put that on her lips because it's our question. It's something
that somebody will come up with in a class, and you're hoping you have the answer if you're the
teacher. And the question and the answer are here, which is great. So while I was thinking of this,
she said, "My beloved Jesus moved in my interior, and through a light that he sent to me, that's
infused knowledge." He said, "My daughter, first of all, before Adam withdrew from my will,
he was my son." Now, before the fall, he's a son. After the fall, he's a servant, a completely
different relationship. He was my son. He contained my will, and he contained the divine will as the
center of his life, and of all of his acts. So all of his acts were divine will acts. Therefore,
he possessed a strength, a dominion, and attractiveness, which was all divine, because his acts were
divine will. His breath, his heartbeat, his acts gave of the divine. All of his being gave off a
celestial fragrance, which drew us all towards him. Now, also all has to be Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit, because for Adam, it's before the saints. Okay. So we felt wounded. Now, I've always questioned
that word in these writings, and I think it means touched, that something got through to us, because
we use the word wounded, meaning in injury. Okay, and it's not being used in that term. So we felt
touched from all sides by this son. If he breathed, if he spoke, if he did even the most innocent,
indifferent, and natural things, they were all touches of love for us. Now look at our acts.
They're not all words. They're not all words. We sometimes make a mistake and think it's all wordy.
If he breathed, if he spoke, if he did even the most innocent, indifferent, and natural things,
they were all touches of love to us. And we, amusing ourselves with him,
filled him more and more with our goods, because everything he did came from one single point,
which courses the divine will, the singularity. And therefore, we liked him all. I think that word
should be fully. We loved him, you know. We found nothing that might displease us. Now, next paragraph,
we slip down to the servant level. So this is after the fall. Now, after sin, Adam descended from
the state of song and reduced himself to the state of servant. I would recommend Luke 15,
the prodigal son. Adam is the first prodigal son. The human race entirely is the second prodigal son.
We as individuals are the third prodigal son. But the first one is Adam. He reduced himself to
the state of servant. And as soon as he broke up with the supreme will, the divine strength,
now notice in the first paragraph, they simply said strength and beauty and attractiveness.
Now you're told that the strength that was in him was a divine strength.
The divine strength, the dominion, the attractiveness, the celestial fragrance went out of him.
It's all gone. Why? Because he's no longer living at the level of divine will. Therefore,
his acts, his being, no longer gave of the divine. This is about as clear as you can get it.
But they were only filled with a human sensation, comes and goes, which making him lose attractiveness
caused that we no longer felt touched, but rather we kept our distance.
He from us and we from him. Now that's illustrated in Genesis chapter 3. Adam, where are you? He was
hiding. His repeating the same acts as those he did before because we're creatures of habit.
So if we're in the habit of doing something, we will continue. As in fact, he did. It doesn't
mean anything. But do you know what the acts of the creature are without the fulfillments of our
will? They're like those foods without condiments and without substance. In other words, tasteless,
which instead of being enjoyed, discussed the human palette. And so these acts discussed the
divine palette as well. They're completely tasteless to the Lord because Adam had already been at this
great height and now he had fallen to a much lower level. And so Jesus tries to describe what this
new food feels like to God. There were like on ripe fruits which contain neither sweetness nor taste.
There were like flowers without fragrance. There were like those vases which are full,
yes, but they're old and fragile and faggot things. In other words, you look at these phases,
remember that's had its day. It's gone. All this can serve a strict necessity for a man and maybe
it'll a shade of the glory of God, but not the happiness and the complete well-being of the creature
and the fullness of the glory of God. Now, he has described perfectly how you descend from this
great height. Okay. So let's look at what Adam actually lost. It's in the next paragraph.
Now, on the other hand, with what pleasure does one not eat a food that is well-flavored and nourishing?
I would strengthen the whole person the mere smell of the condiment at Wet's One's appetite
and eagerness to eat it. The Lord knows as well, doesn't he? In the same way, before sinning,
Adam flavored all his acts with the substance of our will and therefore he wetted the appetite
of our love to take his acts as the most enjoyable food for us because they were divine acts.
And we in return gave him our delicious food, which is our will. But after sin, the poor one lost
the direct way of communication with this Savior. If you have your own book, please color that.
He lost the direct way of communication with his Creator. Pure love was no longer raining in him.
Now, why does he use the word pure? Pure means unmixed with anything else. And once Adam
fell, selfishness gets in, spoiling the love, spoiling the motivation, spoiling everything.
Once sin gets in, you have rush. It's like you have this apple in your hand, you think it's gorgeous
and you cut it and you say, "Mmm, it's not the core." Pure love was no longer raining in him.
Love was divided by apprehension, fear, and since he no longer contained the absolute dominion
of the Supreme Will, his acts of before, done after sin, no longer had the same value.
More so, since the whole of creation, including man, came out of the eternal Creator as their source
of life, in which they were to be preserved only with the life of the Divine Will.
So, a major source of rush came into the human race. Everything was to be founded upon the Divine
Will, and this foundation of the Divine Will was to preserve all things as beautiful and noble,
just as they came from God. The only way we could stay, the way God actually created us,
was to stay in the Divine Will. There just wasn't any other way that it could be done.
And in fact, all created things are as they were created. So, the sun and the moon and the stars
and the plants and everything are exactly as God created them. Man is the only one that destroyed
himself. None of them has lost anything of its origin. Only man lost the life, the foundation,
and therefore he lost his nobility, strength, and likeness to the Creator. But I think it's
an important thing to just note that when man moved from the Divine Will, animals moved away from
man, and we incredibly call them wild. I think we should call the human being wild, and the animals
still doing what God actually intended them to do. Now, we'll go a little bit over the time
tonight, because I want to finish this message. It's not right to leave a message have done.
So, what is the hope for recovery for the human race is the next bit.
But in spite of this, my will did not leave man completely, because you see, you couldn't function.
The eyes couldn't have functioned, the ears couldn't function, the heart, the lungs,
nothing could function if the Divine Will was not actually there. It didn't leave us completely.
Unable to still be the source of life and the foundation of what would sustain him,
because he himself had withdrawn from the Divine Will, the Divine Will offered itself as medicine.
Interesting. So that he might not perish completely. So, my will is medicine,
is sanity, is preservation, is food, is life. It is the fullness of the highest sanctity.
Now, this is going to be elaboration done, and I would suggest just for yourself that you actually
write a list. It's actually very helpful to write a list of what he's saying here and to go through
it, and it makes it much more available to you. So, in whatever way the human being wants the
Divine Will, that is the way the Divine Will offers itself. This is very, very interesting.
If the soul wants the Divine Will as medicine, the Divine Will offers itself in order to take away
from her the fever of passions, the weakness of impatience, the vertical of pride of this very
fascinating language. If she wants the Divine Will as sanity, it offers itself to preserve
her healthy, to free her from any spiritual illness. If she wants the Divine Will as food,
it gives itself as food to make her strength develop, we would say, to make her strong.
And to let her grow more in sanctity. If she wants the Divine Will as life,
and as the fullness of sanctity, oh, then my Will makes beast, because it sees man returning
into the womb of its origin from which he came. And the Divine Will offers itself to give him the
likeness of his Creator, Genesis 1, 27, and Romans 8, 31, I think it is. If the Divine Will
left him, he would resolve into nothing. And if man does not give himself in letting my Will make
him a saint, my Will uses ways to at least save him. I find that fascination. That if we're open at
all, the Lord will work within us. Now, I think that paragraph has answers for all of you who are
teaching classes to others at various stages of the thing, because there will be people at various
stages of growth in the Divine Will. And you'll be able to say to them that if you need the Divine
Will as medicine, this is what he will do. If you need the Divine Will as sanctity or sanity,
this is what it will do. And for those who are growing towards maturity in the Divine Will,
if you want the Divine Will in its fullness, then just surrender, open up. Now, in the next
and final paragraph of this message, we have Jesus saying that in order to be medicine and to bring
us to the fullness of holiness, he had to become the tree of life for us, because it was at the tree
of life that man fell. So Jesus had to become the tree of life for us. It was the fruits of the
earth that pull man down, then it's the fruits of Divine Will that's got to restore him. So Jesus
had to pay this price in order to restore us to the fullness of health. So on hearing this,
Louisa said to herself, Jesus, my love, if you love so much that your will operate in the creature
as in the act in which you created her, it's very awkward. In other words, if you really want
us to come back to the way you created us, that's what she's saying, as if there was no fracture
between your will and that of us, why incoming on the earth? In other words, when you came as
redeemer in the incarnation, why do you do it then? Why have you waited all this time?
Okay, that's what she's saying. Why do you give us this great good that your will triumphant
in everything would place us in the order of creation, just as came out of the hands of the
celestial father? So Jesus coming out of my interior, pressed me all to his heart and with
unspeakable tenderness, he told me, my daughter, the primary purpose of my coming on the earth was
indeed to bring everybody back into the divine will, but you've got to prepare the way for it.
How can you have celestial fruits if the tree isn't there? You have to have the celestial tree
first. So I'll give you John 15 for the vine and its branches. Okay, I'll give you Calvary because
that was when Jesus became the tree of life. So certainly my primary purpose in coming upon the
earth was indeed this one that man would return into the womb of my will as he came out of it
when he was created. But in order to do this, I had to form by means of my humanity, the root,
the trunk, the branches, the leaves, the flowers from which these celestial fruits of my will were
to come out. In other words, the church had to be planted, it had to grow, it had to develop,
it had to mature, it had to spread out, it had to produce flowers and leaves and then fruits
or leaves and flowers and fruits, whatever. In other words, it was going to take time. It couldn't
happen overnight. Therefore, the fruits of my will will certainly come. But in order to desire the
fruits, one must know how precious they are, the good that they bring, the riches that they produce.
We say to one another, oh, do buy that fruit, it's really good for you and it does this and it does
that and it does the other. That's the language Jesus is using here. Here is the reason then for
my many manifestations of my will, which I have made to you. In fact, knowledge will bring the desire
to eat it. Now we keep on getting this emphasis throughout the volumes of Louisa, that knowledge,
it's all about coming to know and understand because then we will reach out to receive it.
Once they have enjoyed what it means, that is through knowledge, to live by my will,
if not all, at least part of them will return to the path of my volition. Now, there is Jesus
being very realistic. When he was on the earth in the incarnation, hundreds of thousands of people
heard him, huge crowds came to his meetings. But when it came to the passion of Jesus,
where were they? It was only the little group that regrouped in the resurrection that became the
seeds of the church. And St. Paul tells us that at the ascension of Jesus, there were only 500.
They were the 500 mustard seeds that went out to create this great tree. And that was out of all
of the tens of thousands. And Jesus is saying here as well, that of all the people who will
listen to the teachings of the divine will, not everybody will actually surrender their will to God.
They won't, not everybody will succeed in getting into that place. And he's very realistic about it.
When they've enjoyed what it means to live only in my will, if not all, at least part of them
will return to the path of my volition. The two wills will exchange the perennial kiss.
There will be no more dispute between the human will and that of the creator. And after the many
fruits that it has given, my redemption will also give the fruit of the feared volunteers to on earth
as it is in heaven. Therefore, you should be the first one to take this fruit. That's Louisa and
then us after her. You should want no other food nor any other life but my will alone.
So a tiny comment here, Eve ate of the wrong fruit and Louisa is being invited here to eat
of the tree of life. And you and I are being invited also to eat only of this tree of life.
So thank you for coming and I wish you every blessing and happiness and grace for 2021.